اهلا حلقه هذا الاسبوع من البعد الاخر
ستكون مختلفه عما سبقها وستكون بمثابه
الاستراحه من السياسه ساخصصها لامر ربما
هو اهم من السياسه كيف يمكن التمكين
لملايين الشباب العرب والاخذ بايديهم
للحاق بموكب الانسانيه ساتحدث الى عضو
بارز في عده مؤسسات تمويلا للشركات
الناشئه السيد عبد الله الاعرج الرئيس
المشارك في مؤسسه الشرق الاوسط للاستثمار
وفي مؤسسه مستثمرون رياض
الملائكيين من العربيه احييكم اينما كنتم
انا منتهى الرمحي وهذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
في خضم اخبار التوتر الاجتماعي والسياسيه
في تونس مثلا في بدايه هذا العام تسللت
ثلاثه اخبار تهم استحواذ شركات اجنبيه على
شركات تونسيه ناشئه ابرزها شركات انستديب
التي اشترتها شركه بوينتك مكتشفه لقاح
كورونا المثير في الاخبار الثلاثه ان
تخصصات الشركات الناشئه التونسيه التي جرى
الاستحواذ عليها ليست في البيع والشراء
الالكتروني او غيرها من الميادين السهله
التي اعتدنا رؤيتها في المنطقه ولكن
جميعها في الذكاء الاصطناعي والعاب
الفيديو وانترنت الاشياء
لا تثبت صفقه اقتناء استديب التونسيه من
قبل بايونتك الالمانيه بمبلغ 700 مليون
دولار وهو ثلث ما تسعى تونس للحصول عليه
من صندوق النقد في مفاوضات شاقه لا تثبت
الصفقه ان هناك خزانا جديدا في تونس يمكنه
اعاده بناء البلاد وانما ايضا تفتح املا
في المنطقه العربيه كلها لاعاده تقديم
نفسها على انها جزء من العالم يمكنه ان
يعول على نفسه في حل مشاكله بل والتاثير
في موكب الانسانيه
تجدر الاشاره الى ان جمع راس المال الخاص
لم يكن اسهل من اي وقت مضى بالنسبه
للتكنولوجيا في العالم هذه الايام كما
يتضح من مشاركه سوفت بنك اليابانيه التي
تساهم فيه السعوديه فضلا عن صناديق
انشاتها الرياض لرعايه الشركات الناشئه في
العالم ولا سيما في المنطقه العربيه
اسمحوا لي ان ارحب بضيفنا السيد عبد الله
معنا في هذه الحلقه اهلا بك معنا السيد
عبد الله اهلا وسهلا
بوجود معكم اهلا بك انا ابدا معك اولا
بتقييمك لصفقات الاستحواذ على الشركات
الناشئه في بدايه هذا العام احنا اشرنا
لصفقه مهمه تمت في تونس وراينا صفقات مهمه
ايضا في اوروبا والولايات المتحده كيف
ممكن نقيم اقتناء الشركات او عمليه
الاستحواذ على الشركات الصغيره
شكرا لك وموضوع حيوي ومهم للجميع لنا
كمستثمرين وللشعب العربي بشكل عام
بالنسبه لنا سماع مثل هذه الاخبار يعتبر
بادره امل ومحفز كبير جدا
للشباب الذي يبحث عن اثبات ذاته واثبات
نفسه في ميادين كانت حصرا على مجتمعات
معينه
والشباب العربي اثبت قدرته الكبيره جدا
المعرفيه والمهنيه والحرفيه من ناحيه
المهارات التي اكتسبها لتطوير بلدانهم زي
ما ذكرت في التقرير ومثال نستجيب اللي
ذكرته في التقرير مثال مشرف لنا جميعا
كعرب ويثبت انه نهضه بلداننا لن تتم الا
بسواعد ابنائنا بس لو قيمنا المشهد العام
بشكل عام للشركات الناشئه في المنطقه
العربيه الى اي مدى يمكن ان نرى فيها امل
مثلا لحل المشاكل التي تو بعض الدول يعني
في في معاناه مع صندوق النقد الدولي هل
يمكن ان تكون هذه باب مثلا
للمزيد من الدخل في هذه البلدان بالفعل
يعني احد يعني الاهداف المعلنه والغير
معلنه لدعم الشركات التقنيه الناشئه في في
مختلف البلدان هو لتنميه اقتصادياتها وما
شهدناه يعني من دخول مستثمرين عالميين
لشركات تقنيه محليه سواء في السعوديه او
في الامارات او في مصر او في في تونس او
غيرها من البلدان العربيه اكبر دليل على
يعني
الرؤيه الواضحه لدعم مثل هذه الشركات منذ
نشاتها وهو بالفعل يدعم اقتصاديات المنطقه
ويجلب استثمارات للمنطقه ويدعم كذلك
المهارات المطلوبه
لتنميه وانشاء مثل الش التقنيه اللي تخدم
مجتمعاتنا والمجتمع بشكل عام
كيف تمدح التمويلات يعني ما هي اليه منح
هذه التمويلات للشركات الناشئه ما هي
المعايير المحدده لذلك
بالنسبه للتمويل يعتقد انه يعني كل صندوق
تمويل
بيتخصص في مرحله معينه من التمويل كصندوق
يتخصص في مجال معين من من الصناعه التي
يتم التركيز عليها فنجد بعض الصناديق
التمويليه تتركز في مناطق جرى في جغرافيه
معينه بعض الصناديق تتركز في مراحل معينه
من المشاريع ما نسميها بالمرحله قبل
البذره او البريسيد مراحل البذره سيد او
مراحل متاخره من من نمو المشروع وكذلك
يعني نجد صناديق تمويليه تتخصص كذلك في
صناعات معينه صناديق تتركز في تقنيه
الماليه صناديق تتركز في
التقنيه الحيويه صناديق تتركز في الاي اي
وغيرها من الصناعات وكذلك يوجد صناديق
لا تركز على التقنيه يعني الاستثمارات
يعني ممكن حصرها باستثمارات في مجال
التقنيه او استثمارات خارج مجال التقنيه
فالحديث اعتقد انه حيكون في مجال التقنيه
بشكل عام فهذا هذا هذا هذا المحدد الاول
اللي هو
مجال اختصاص الصندوق للاستثمار
زي مثل ما ذكرنا انه كل صندوق له تركيز
على مجال معين صحيح بس هل اصبحت الامور
اسهل لتمويل الشركات الناشئه المتعلقه
بالتكنولوجيا كلما تذكر كيف كانت قصه
انشاء الفيسبوك كم كم يعني
تعب مؤسسوه من اجل الحصول على تمويلات
ماليه هل بعد النجاح وبعد هذا التقدم
التكنولوجي اصبحت الافكار المتعلقه
بالتكنولوجيا
قابله اكثر للفهم من اجل التمويل بكل
تاكيد رحله رياده الاعمال تعتبر رحله شاقه
وليست بالسهله
رحله رائد الاعمال تبدا من من
اقتناع المحيط
القريب من من صاحب الفكره او رائد الاعمال
او رائد الاعمال
بتبني مشروعه ومن ثم دعمه
استثماريا لو لو نذكر مراحل الاستثمار من
الاساس تتم عن طريق الاهل والاصدقاء
بعدها تنتقل للاينج او المستثمرين
الملائكين بعدها تنتقل الى مراحل اخرى من
من من حيث الاستثمار عن طريق صناديق
الاستثمار الجري
فبالتاكيد حتى في الاسواق الناضجه رحله
رحله رائد الاعمال تعتبر رحله شاقه مثلها
مثل رحله رائد الاعمال في البلدان العربيه
في البلدان
التي يعني المنظومه تعتبر وصلت الى مرحله
مرحله النضج الخيارات تعتبر اكثر
لرائد الاعمال او رائد الاعمال البحث عن
الممولين وكذلك فهم الممولين لنوع
المخاطره التي يعني هم بصدد باخذها في هذا
النوع من الشركات فهي شركات تعتبر عاليه
المخاطر ولما نقول عاليه المخاطر المخاطر
بمعنى انه المستثمر ممكن ان يفقد كامل راس
ماله في عندما يستثمر في فرصه معينه لذلك
المشهد في في الغرب او في الشرق تطور تطور
بشكل كبير في العالم العربي ولله الحمد
مشاهده نقلات يعني جدا كبيره خلال العشر
سنوات السابقه وطبعا العالم العربي يعني
منطقه جغرافيه كبيره لما نتكلم عن العلم
العربي نتكلم عن بلدان مختلفه بعضها خطط
خطوات جدا ممتازه لدعم رياده الاعمال
والصناديق الاستثماريه ونذكر على راس
القائمه السعوديه والام مصر وهي اتت
بالفعل على راس القائمه في حجم التمويلات
التي تمت في عام
لذلك اجابه على سؤالك استاذه منتهى الرحله
ليست سهله شاقه في البلدان المتطوره وفي
بلدان العالم العربي صحيح بس في نصيحه
مثلا ذهبيه ممكن تقديمها لهؤلاء الشباب
بتعرف في عالم الرومانسيه
يقال لهم دائما ان تؤمن بما تقوم به وان
يعني تبقى
ملاحقا لحلمك حتى اللحظه الاخيره هل هذه
كافيه ام ان الايمان بما يقوم به الشخص
يجب ان يكون مدعوم ايضا
بايمان بمن حوله او ايمان للشركات او
المؤسسات او حتى الدوله بتمويله انا اعتقد
اذا لم كممولين اذا لم نجد فريق عمل مؤمن
بما يقوم به
هذا بالنسبه للممول هذا بالنسبه لهم يعتبر
ديل بريكر فالممول لن يقوم بالتمويل اذا
لم يجد فريق مؤمن بالفكره اللي هو شغال
عليها هذا رقم واحد رقم اثنين لازم يكون
السوق كبير جدا
للنجاح لانه المستثمر ورائد الاعمال كل
منهما يسعى الى الربح وهي يعني هي عباره
عن
وين وين زي ما نقول للجميع لرائد الاعمال
ولا المستثمر لذلك هي رحله طويله اذا لم
يوجد شغف لدى رائد الاعمال بما يقوم به او
فريق العمل بشكل عام وكذلك من وجهه نظر
المستثمر ايمان بالسوق وبالفريق المؤسس
لما هم بصدد القيام فيه لان رحله طويله
ثمان سنوات سبع سنوات هي متوسط رحله رائد
الاعمال في هذه الرحله فالوصايا
الرومانسيه اللي احنا نسمعها دائما هي
حقيقه لكن بنفس الوقت يفترض انها تدعم
بالحقائق والخبرات
فالمستثمر اذا وجد شغف وكذلك خبرات وكذلك
سوق كبير
قابل
انه رائد الاعمال بامكانه الوصول اليه هذا
كل ما يسعى لهذه الاعمال وكذلك المستثمر
نحكي شويه عن المستثمر حضرتك ذكرت دكتور
قبل قليل بانه هذا من انواع
التمويلات عاليه المخاطر وممكن المستثمر
يخسر كل الاموال التي وضعها في في هذه
الستار او الشركه الناشئه
هل هي يعني بشكل محسومه ولا مساله وقت
يعني عندما نستثمر بالتعليم نتائجه لا
تظهر اليوم او غدا مش مثل ما بنستثمر في
مطعم او في بوتيك وكذلك في الشركات
التكنولوجيه هل من من عرضت عليه مشاريع
ولم يستثمر فيها نادم الان هل سمعت عن احد
ندم من المستثمرين ما دخل بهذا المشروع
اللي كان معروض عليه وخسر
المستثمرين في نقاش دائم بينهم وبين بعض
وبينهم وبين انفسهم على الفرصه اللي
فوتوها
يعني في فرص كبيره للمستثمر ممكن
يقرر عدم الدخول فيها لسبب من او لاخر فلو
كل المستثمرين عرفوا بالنتائج كيف ستكون
الجميع سيدخل في نفس الفرصه اذا قبل رائد
الاعمال في قبولهم كمستثمرين
يعني الفرق بين الاستثمارات التقليديه
والاستثمارات التقنيه مثل ما تفضلتي انه
الاستثمارات التقليديه مخاطرها قليله جدا
يوجد
عاده موجوده لدى يعني صاحب المشروع بينما
في المشاريع التقنيه غالبا
انه الاسس ما تكون موجوده ما في الاسيس
عباره عن افكار واكواد برمجيه
او ابحاث يتم البناء عليها
المستثمرين في
صراع دائما مع انفسهم للبحث عن افضل
الفرصه المتاحه وكذلك يعني بكل تاكيد هم
مقتنعين انه في نهايه المطاف
مستحيل انهم يدخلوا في كل الفرص احنا
دائما نقول يعني يعني المجال اللي احنا
فيه عباره عن
للشركات فاحنا نقول لا لعدم الاستثمار
اكثر مما يقول نعم للاستثمار لانه نعم
غالبا تتم لعدد محدد من الشركات بناء على
زي مثلا ذكرنا قبل قليل على مجال عامل
الصندوق والتركيز الجغرافي اللي يركز
عليها الصندوق وكذلك ايمان الشركاء في
الصندوق بالفرصه ومن الممكن جدا انه يعني
بعض الفرص تضيع على المستثمر وهذه احد
قواعد اللعبه الف شكر لك للمشاركه معنا
دكتور عبد الله الاعرج رئيس المشارك في
مؤسسه الشرق الاوسط للاستثمار وفي مؤسسه
مستثمروا الرياض الملائكيين شكرا جزيلا لك
على المشاركتي معنا ارجو ان تبقى معنا
فاصل قصير ونعود بعده
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد ونعود لمناقشه
موضوع الشركات الناشئه ودورها في اعاده
النهوض بالاقتصاديات العربيه ينضم الينا
الان محمد الزعبي الرئيس الشريك الاداري
لشركه لمى للاستثمار الجريء وهي صندوق
تمويل تاسيسي يركز على دعم الابتكار في
مجال التكنولوجيا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
خاصه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه اهلا بك
معنا استاذ محمد
يا اهلا وسهلا كيف الحال
بدي ابدا معك اهلا بك لو تعطينا فكره عن
حجم نشاطاتكم والتمويلات التي منحتوها حتى
الان
بالنسبه لصندوق النمر استثمرنا بخمسه
وثلاثين فرصه استثماريه اعلنا عن 32 وان
شاء الله سنععلن عن ثلاثه قادمين
كصندوق لا نعلم بالضبط كم نستثمر لكن في
مراحل
او ما قبل البذره والبذره الشكل الاولي من
مئه الف الى 300 الف دولار امريكي وشرك
السيد من 300 الى الى مليون ما يعادل
تقريبا فيك تعطينا فكره عن على ماذا تركزت
هذه الفرص التي منحتوها تمويل حتى الان
بالنسبه لصندوقنا احنا ما نسمى بالسكته
بمعنى انه ما في اي مجال معين نريد ان نرى
كلمه
في الشركه التقنيه الناشئه فنتاك
لكن في مجالات اهم من مجالات يعني بنتك في
في في وطننا العربي يحظى باهتمام كثير من
ناحيه التقييم من ناحيه فرص التخرج فبكون
عليها تركيز اكثر من امور قد تكون مثلا في
المحتوى او كلها مهمه لكن في يعني بعض
المجالات اهم المجالات اخرى طيب في اي
مرحله يبدو نظام الشركات الناشئه في
المنطقه العربيه حاليا هل يمكننا ان نقول
انه بلاغ مرحله النضوج
بالنسبه لقانون الشركات احنا في بدايه
الطريق او يعني في الحجر الاساس اليوم
كصناديق مثل صندوق نمى اللي يستثمر في
مستخدم
او يعني القروض القابله للتحول الى الى
اسد الى الى اسهم
واشهرها حاضنه عندها
للاسف اليوم لا نستطيع ان نستخدم بعض هذه
الادوات في قوانين الشركات
المحليه ولذلك نطلب من
شركاتنا شركات تقنيه في منطقتنا ان تؤسس
الهولدينج القابضه في اماكن
القانون الشركات فيها ناضج بحيث تستحوذ
هذه الشركات القابضه على الشركات المحليه
مئه بالمئه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وزاره الاستثمار تقدم هذا الخدمه من خلال
انترنوش لانه نحن كصندوق راس مال جريء
نستثمر باقليه ولكن محوكب نطلب بعض الحقوق
حقوق معرفه حقوق محافظه على النسب لا يمكن
تطبيقها اليوم في قوانين الشركات الحاليه
ولكن ابشرك قانون الشركات السعودي الجديد
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه الجديد يعالج
99% من هذه المشكله ونحن يعني متحمسين جدا
في يعني صدد يعني
صدد ان يتم الاعلان عنه بضل موضوع من
سيكون الطرف الجريء يكون اول من يستخدم
هذا هذا يعني هذا القوانين بس احنا سواء
صناديق راس مال جريئه المفروض نكون يعني
من اول الناس من اجرى الناس طيب
الجهات التي ذكرتها هي جهات محليه ولا
جهات دوليه اللي بيتم يعني التعامل معها
بالنسبه
للتفسير الشركات القابضه يعني المتعارف
عليه
الدلوة في امريكا ولايه
هي اكثر استخداما في العالم واكثر من يعني
يرغب فيها الصناديق الراسماليه في امريكا
وهي يعني الانبا سنتر لهذا العالم
كيمن نستخدمها كثيرا
في في الشرق
ونقسمبرغ في اوروبا لكن نحن في في صدره
يعني تحسين قوانيننا المحليه
كل يوم تطويرها محليه نعم وهذا بيجعلنا
نتساءل عن انه هناك تقارير تتحدث عن بلوغ
سوق الامريكيه مرحله الاشباع الى اي حد
توافق على ذلك وليست هذه فرصه للتوجه
والتركيز على الاسواق العربيه الاسواق
المحليه اما ان هناك يعني ظروف تمنع من
ذلك
انا يعني
كشخص في عالم الاستثمار ياتي مصطلح يعني
الاسد اللوكيشن او توزيع الاصول المستثمر
الذكي يعني لا تضع يعني في سله واحده حتى
في الاسواق الامريكيه وزع في الباب
وبعد الالوكيشن للسوق الامريكي انظر الى
سوقك هنا سوق المحلي في الاسهم فنحن جزء
من الاسد
فانظر الى الصناديق
يعني لا انظر الى تشبع انظر اليها توزيع
اصول والمستثمر الذكي ما بتعرفي ممكن يكون
سوق يعني في مرحله ضعف يغطي عليه السوق
الاخر ممكن
نوع من الضعف انا
بجيب العائد اللي اطلبه من البنشر كافر
يعني الكثير من المستثمرين المحليين
ينظروا الى صندوق نما لتوزيع فيه عالم
الهايروس طبعا صحيح نستثمر في اوائل مرحله
الشركات التقييم الناشئه لكن انضربت تغطي
على يعني معظم العائد
لتجنيه من استثمارك في القابلك فهي يعني
توزيع اصول براي وبتعمل توازن يعني خساره
من جهه وربح من جهه اخرى بس هناك شركات
ناشئه يعني اذا صح السؤال توظف عدد قليل
من
الموظفين وهذه الشركات
الناشئه
مثل ابل مثل غيرها هي عدد قليل من
الموظفين بعكس شركات اخرى توظف الالاف من
العاملين لديهم ما الفرق بينهما
والله سؤال صعب ولكن يعني الجواب مصطلحين
ياتوا في في بالي
التوسع والكفاءه يعني انت ذكرتي بعض
الشركات
ابل على هذا التليفون هو تليفون
ومكتبك للعمل وكاميرا وجهازك الموسيقي
وهناك كفاءه عاليه تقدمها الشركات التقنيه
لا تستطيع الشركات التقليديه
يعني اكبر شركه
اوتيلات في العالم لا تمتلك فندق واحد
اكبر شركه تاكسي في العالم اوبر لا تمتلك
سياره واحده
لترى في الشركات
التقنيه لا يعني مستحيل ان ترى مرادف لها
في الشركات التقليديه هذا هذا الكود اللي
في هذا التطبيقات يخدم عشره يخدم مئه يخدم
الف يخدم مئه مليون شركات تقليديه محكومه
هذا برايي الفرق
شو خطط الممولين السعوديين لهذا العام
والله انا لا استطيع ان عن الممولين تحدثت
لان لكل صندوق خصوصياته لكن سواء
احنا في عالمنا لانه احنا نعتبر يعني ما
يسمى
يعني ما اخفي عليك منبسط لما يكون الماكرو
كلايم شوي صعب لانه ما نستثمر فيه اليوم
فرص التخرج في سيكون من اربع الى خمس سنين
فبكون في زي ما تقولي
تحسن في في الوضع العام
فاحنا متحمسين جدا لهذه السنه
وينقلب السوق من سوق يعني
يصير في يعني
التقييمات بصير فيها انخفاض اصلا انت
كريادي بالتاسيس في هذا الوقت اصبح ارخص
لك الاجارات نزلت تكلفه التشغيل نزلت يعني
نرى
اولويه واهتمام اكثر من ميادين اخرى
كصندوق نبعد عن بعض المجالات
[موسيقى]
تمويل بسهوله اكثر من لدى الغرب لكن في
منطقتنا يتجه معظم التمويل للمشاريع التي
ليس لها قيمه مضافه غالبيه الشركات اللي
بتحصل على التمويل هي متخصصه بعمليات
البيع الالكتروني اكثر منها افكار ممكن ان
تغير المجتمع
للامانه يعني هناك اهتمام كبير من
الحكومات في المنطقه
ونرى في المملكه العربيه السعوديه جهد
كبير على القطاع الصناعي بس بالنسبه يعني
صناديق راس المال الجليل نحن لا نستثمر في
هذا المجال لانه نموذج العمل مختلف هذه
الافكار الصناعيه تحتاج الى تمويل عالي
جدا في بدايه طريقه تحتاج الى جهات
وتشريعات صناديق راس المال الجريء يعني ما
هي قدها
فبتعرف في مجال تكنولوجي انت وصديقك
تستطيع ان تقدموا وانتم في بيتكم انتم في
الكراج وانتم في الكافيه منتج قد يخدم
الكثير الكثير المشروع الصناعي يحتاج الى
تمويل عالي جدا شموع التقني في عالم
التكنولوجيا يحتاج الى طريق مكمل بادوار
مكمله من هو يعني البياع اللي وجد المشكله
يترجم هذه الفيجن او هذا الفكر الى كود
ومن هو العمليات لا تحتاج تمويل او تحتاج
تمويل بعد منتجك الاولي
فهو نموذج عمل يعني
انبات بعض الصناديق ولكن هناك صناديق يعني
عندها اهميه اكثر او مربوطه في مراكز بحث
او مربوطه ممكن تستثمر في المشاريع
الصناعيه السيد محمد الزعبي الرئيس الشريك
الاداري لشركه نما للاستثمار الجريء وهي
كما قلنا صندوق تمويل تاسيسي يركز على دعم
الابتكار في مجال التكنولوجيا في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط شكرا جزيلا لك على المشاركه
معنا الف شكر والى هنا مشاهدينا الكرام
انتهت حلقه اليوم من البعد الاخر يمكنكم
دائما متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب كما
يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا على العربيه
بودكاست الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]